مما سمعته من الأشخاص الذين
تحدثوا إليه، بدا في الواقع أقل
انفعالًا مع توجهه إلى اليوم مما كان عليه في لوائح
الاتهام الثلاثة السابقة، والتي لا
تزال جملة رائعة ليقولها، لكنه
لا يريد أن يتم تصويره على أنه
لا يريد أن يكون كذلك.  تم القبض عليه، فهو لا
يريد أن يكون لديه ما في ذهنه هو
إهانة الذهاب إلى هذا السجن ومن
ثم تعلم أن الخضوع لصورة
ولقطة وبصمات الأصابع، وإلى
وجهة نظرك حول صوره، فإن الأمر
ليس مجرد  أنه يريد أن يبدو
مهددًا وهو أمر صحيح بالتأكيد وهو لقد
صنع هذا النوع من الوجه في
الصور لسنوات وسنوات وسنوات
ولا يريد أن يبدو ضعيفًا وهذا هو
ما يدور حوله وهكذا تعلمون
تعميم صورة القدح لجمع التبرعات
من امتلاكه واستخدامه للصحافة،
هذا كله جزء من قواعد اللعبة التي
رأيناه يستخدمها مرارًا وتكرارًا
ولكن هذا لا يعني أنه يستمتع بأي
من هذا، هذا هو الشيء الخطير الذي يواجهه
وهو يواجه عقوبة السجن الخطيرة